[Musique]
c'est l'idée de renverser les codes et
les conventions et d'essayer de en
mettant un piano à 90 degrés c'est
d'essayer de proposer aux spectateurs un
autre regard sur les choses les choses
qu'on voit tous les jours qui sont
d'après notre notre avis c'est normal
qu'un piano il est tellement lourd qu'il
est sur une scène et ben en le mettant à
la verticale on peut peut-être imaginer
que d'autres choses peuvent être
différentes si on les regarde
différemment
c'était ça l'idée de base
[Musique]
c'est une surprise que je ne savais pas
où le piano est tellement je pense
qu'ils étaient accrochés aux immeubles
mais en fait il est accroché à la grue
alors c'était vraiment l'effet surprise
non s'est super bien passé un bon moment
c'est dommage il ya eu quelques gouttes
d'eau
[Musique]
on s'était de confronter le côté
classique brillant noeud papillon et
queue de pie du piano avec ce monde brut
stridents et et salle du chantier
c'était une très chouette expérience
j'ai trouvé que c'était très beau très
agréable de le voir comme ça bougeait
dans le ciel et ses notes de piano qui
résonne le casque c'est agréable
le son de la musique dans le casque je
crois que c'était une expérience très
agréable
donc j'avais des petits arbres les
feuilles moi dans mon champ de vision
c'était super
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était une expérience hors du commun
magique allier le btp à l'univers de la
musique c'était juste voilà super
politique une beau moment de poésie
urbaine
alors en tout cas c'est une joie de
pouvoir rejouer et d'être peut-être un
des premiers spectacles d'après d'après
confinement et du coup voilà si on peut
justement prolonger le regard sur le
regarde différemment des choses avec
cette proposition artistique je suis sûr
à vie
[Musique]